you know what's the most appealing thing
about a cooking video is watching
someone preparing food with band-aids
all over their fingers fun shoot let's
do it
No whoa this just got a sexy kitchen but
would be weird if I actually knew what I
was doing today of course it would hi my
name is Grace Tommy if you don't know
know your know your life is different
now I'm cooking something today you're
know what it is by the title of this
video I've done a lot of cooking videos
on this channel and a lot of it is you
can cut to the chase
elegant stoner food and that's been fun
but now I actually want to learn to cook
things so I thought maybe I'll start
like a pseudo series here on this
channel where I try to cook recipes from
actual chefs or people that know how to
cook things and the first person I
thought of that I truly think is
absolutely wonderful
is Chrissy Teigen I think she's great
and if you don't like her go [ __ ]
yourself I mean you're all entitled to
your opinion but she's the first person
I thought of that I wanted to try to
recreate a recipe from this is her
cookbook called cravings which yeah oh I
don't have a title for this pseudo
series on my channel so let me know what
you think it should be grace tries to
cook domestic grace this grace under
fire that seems like that one's probably
copy written anyway and I bought the
book it literally in my car after I
bought it just kind of randomly opened
up to a page and I found the perfect
recipe for me to try to make this first
go-round actual drunken noodles this
seems absolutely perfect she writes
about actual drunken noodles the funny
thing about drunken noodles is that none
of the recipes I've ever found actually
have alcohol in them we're supposed to
eat them while drunk as a hangover cure
I am NOT opposed but I decided they'd be
good actually drunk themselves so I
added whiskey she's perfect it looks
absolutely beautiful so we're gonna try
to make Chrissy Teigan actual drunken
noodles today that only took me seven
minutes to introduce in honor of making
actual drunken noodles I saw Cheers
I got as many of the ingredients that I
could find there's a couple things that
I don't have and we're already starting
off with a handicap but we're gonna try
our best first thing we need to do is
make the sauce that means in a bowl
we're gonna combine six tablespoons of
light brown sugar this is
old and pretty crusty you're also
allowed to describe my YouTube presence
as that sick good job one half cup of
soy sauce
she says regular not that like half a
cup and that's my impression of terrible
ASMR get in there 1/4 cup of oyster
sauce in my grocery store they had
oysters flavored sauce I could have gone
to another grocery store to try to find
the actual ingredients but I got tired
oh that smells like a wet bathing suit
thank God duck in a wet cardboard box
and left it like a Jeep Cherokee in the
middle of the desert for a few weeks
let's put it in the food we want to eat
Chrissy a truss Oh two tablespoons of
whiskey doesn't say what type of whiskey
is better than other types oh I just got
some Jack Daniels one
Cheers one tablespoon mirin this I could
not find at my grocery store and I
looked it up and I couldn't find it and
so I actually forgot I'm they wanted to
look up what is a substitute dry sherry
sweet marsala dry white wine and rice
vinegar will do the trick
I might have rice vinegar oh my god I
have it we're gonna try a little bit of
it a tablespoon
yikes should I even bother I'm not gonna
look at the expiration date there we go
a tablespoon sambal oelek I'm
pronouncing that insanely wrong I got it
here we go oh oh how did that happen
they're a little less than a tablespoon
because I'm a baby oh I forgot to wash
my hands before all this I also forgot
that none of you are eating it doesn't
really matter so we need one tablespoon
of chopped garlic which I'm gonna do
right now but the other main thing that
I forgot is that in general we need 12
ounces of dried wide rice noodles or one
and a half pounds of fresh wide rice
noodles my grocery store didn't have
either one of them
they had Japanese food on which I know
is not right and then I had a bunch of
egg noodles I guess
we're not many handicaps I'm gonna
prepare these egg noodles the way
they're supposed to be prepared that
tablespoon of chopped garlic goes into
the soft blue eschatos oh the sauce is
quite an odor oh yeah I would jump ship
now - okay that sauce is made and now
we're moving on to the actual length
recipe no something's has a lot like
children all the ingredients in the
process of becoming like their fully
actualized self are really finishing
annoying and have to be babysat and it
stresses you out but then if you do it
right the final product because you're
really proud oh I gotta cut my chicken
we need a one and a quarter pounds of
boneless skinless chicken breast cut
into half inch cubes okay for the rest
of the meal we need to prepare or
tablespoons of canola oil oh I'm an
Olympic athlete I need four eggs beaten
I have two eggs you know what I believe
in you eggs you're gonna be as good as
double your normal goodness oh there's a
shell in it good dang it two eggs eaten
four scallions thinly sliced hey I'm
gonna prep the rest of the ingredients
and show you them when they're done on
our 300 South trying this in a wok or a
really big skillet heat one tablespoon
of canola oil then basically cook the
eggs until they're scrambled or curdled
and then set them aside to cool them
meanwhile workers have tossed this
chicken in sesame oil and salt let's do
that
holy [ __ ] that smells amazing teaspoon
and so chick run up another tablespoon
of canola oil in our wok and then we're
gonna add the chicken we're gonna add
the chicken for like four to five
minutes once the chicken has been just
cooked through where it's no longer pink
I'm gonna transfer that to the bowl of
eggs but I'm gonna put two more
tablespoons of canola oil in the pan I'm
gonna put my ginger my garlic and my
scallions in there to get fragrant for
like 20 seconds
anyway add the broccoli mushroom and
rock and let that cook for 2-3 minutes
cooking is fun
I think I put in way too much broth but
that's okay we're gonna add the noodles
egg and chicken and the supposin sauce
probably why this is in the recipe right
cook and toss this for 4 to 5 minutes
ok who's barely just woke up from her 7
p.m. to 9 p.m. nap so she is fully awake
for the rest of night but we did it look
at this look at this it's super string
hot but I want to try it and like we
said yep that's not where I'm at right
now like I've said I've had many
handicaps along the way these are
probably not the right noodles I missed
on the mirin sauce there's a couple
other things that were complicated but
this smells amazing here we go chrissy
teigen
actual drunken noodles that's so good
holy that is so good i literally posted
a boomerang of the noodles cooking on my
story and it already got a message from
diane being like yes please
is there a Diane Kang hey hi Dan Kang
can I give this to you I'm so happy
damn yes thank you guys for watching
this episode of whatever the [ __ ] this
is if you guys want me to try to
recreate a certain chef or person please
leave a comment down below because I
want to start doing this I want to start
figuring out an idiot like me to make
recipes that are supposed to be targeted
for idiots like me also don't forget to
subscribe to this YouTube channel I make
videos juices and Thursdays give or take
and if you haven't already maybe hard
and I have a new show it's five days a
week
it's called this might get its over on a
YouTube channel I'll surprise surprise
called this might get so click the links
in description to go subscribe to that
cuz it just launched it's a very
exciting
Oh Matt I don't know but holy this is so
good now I'm in the anger stage you know
there's like six stages of grief there
has to be stages of euphoria denial
anger acceptance Oh